Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Aujourd'hui,
on parle de l'un des plats préférés des Français,
le couscous.
Mais savez-vous d'où il vient ?
Tout le monde n'est pas d'accord.
Du Maroc ? De l'Algérie ?
Vous allez voir que c'est un petit peu plus compliqué que cela.
Bienvenue dans Sur la planche.
Si vous aimez ce format, n'hésitez pas à liker et à vous abonner.
De cette manière, je pourrais continuer à vous faire saliver.
Hmmm..
Le couscous,
les Français en consomment chaque année,
tenez-vous bien,
80000 tonnes.
Et nous ne sommes pas les seuls à adorer ce plat emblématique des pays du Maghreb.
On en mange partout dans le monde.
Alors, pour la plupart des historiens,
sa naissance remonte au Moyen Âge.
Le couscous serait né dans la partie occidentale du Maghreb,
une région qui correspond aujourd'hui
aux territoires du Maroc et de l'Algérie.
Du coup, l'un et l'autre en revendiquent la paternité.
Pour les Marocains, aucun doute, le couscous est un plat maison.
Ce qui, évidemment, fait bondir les Algériens.
Alors, qui a raison ?
Qui a tort ?
Je suis désolé, mais il est impossible de trancher.
Et pour cause...
À l'époque où le couscous a été inventé,
le Maroc et l'Algérie n'existent pas.
Enfin, n'existe pas sous leur forme actuelle.
Le Maghreb occidental
est essentiellement peuplé de tribus berbères,
souvent nomades ou semi-nomades,
qui ne sont pas rattachées à un territoire particulier.
Ce dont on est sûr, en revanche, c'est que le mot couscous
vient de l'arabe "kuskusu".
J'espère que je prononce bien.
Il est apparu pour la première fois
au XIIᵉ siècle dans les livres de cuisine.
Alors on entend dire parfois que ce mot fait référence au bruit
que faisaient les bracelets
des femmes qui manipulaient la semoule...
Mais bon, je n'ai trouvé aucune source qui l'atteste.
Ce mot désigne à la fois le plat et la semoule.
Il s'agit d'une tradition ancestrale
qui s'est transmise de génération en génération.
Dans certaines régions, le couscous était aussi appelé "taam"
nourriture en arabe ou céréale.
Logique car la semoule, on le rappelle, est produite à partir de blé dur,
différent du blé tendre avec lequel on fait du pain.
Pour être complet,
je parle de couscous,
dans certains endroits,
la semoule était parfois remplacée par de l'orge ou des miettes de pain.
On trouve donc de tout dans le couscous.
C'est un plat très équilibré.
Si bien qu'au XIIIᵉ siècle,
il est fortement recommandé par les traités arabes de médecine.
Le plat connaît un tel succès qu'il va se diffuser au gré
des mouvements de population
dans tout le bassin méditerranéen,
au-delà du Maghreb occidental.
On le consomme en Égypte, au Proche et au Moyen-Orient,
mais aussi en Europe.
Il débarque sur notre continent par l'Espagne et le Portugal.
Il faut dire que ces 2 pays ont été sous domination
arabo-musulmane pendant plus de 7 siècles.
En France, on ne le découvre que bien plus tard.
Il s'invite à la table des Français au milieu du XXᵉ siècle.
À partir des années 50-60.
Il traverse la Méditerranée
au moment de l'indépendance de l'Algérie et du Maroc.
Et maintenant, vous êtes incollables sur l'origine du couscous.
Il est temps de passer aux travaux pratiques.
Enfin, à table, direction la cuisine.
En fait,
il n'y a pas un couscous, mais des couscous.
Traditionnellement,
il est composé de viande,
au singulier ou au pluriel.
De l'agneau.
en priorité, c'est le couscous que l'on déguste au Maroc ou en Algérie.
Mais si vous n'aimez pas l'agneau, vous pouvez le déguster avec du bœuf,
ou du poulet.
Et si vous avez vraiment beaucoup d'appétit,
vous pouvez même réunir toutes ces viandes.
Les légumes maintenant...
Je ne voudrais pas casser l'ambiance, mais...
Tu n'as pas oublié un truc essentiel...
Genre, les guez-mer
Mais oui !
On peut aussi agrémenter ce plat
avec des merguez, indispensables pour réaliser un couscous royal.
Je précise cependant une chose, c'est qu'à l'origine,
il n'est pas très populaire au Maghreb,
car les merguez,
telles qu'on les connaît aujourd'hui, c'est-à-dire une saucisse à base
de viande de mouton hachée, est une invention française.
Voilà, je peux revenir aux légumes maintenant ?
OK, c'est bon, tu peux y aller.
Au menu :
carottes, pommes de terre, courgettes, oignons.
On peut aussi mettre des navets ou du chou.
On n'oublie surtout pas...
Les pois chiches.
Non seulement, c'est excellent au goût et c'est aussi
très bon pour la santé.
Ils sont riches en protéines, en vitamines et aussi en fibres.
La viande, les légumes,
il ne manque plus qu'une chose...
C'est la semoule !
On l'a dit, elle est obtenue à partir de blé dur.
Les grains sont débarrassés de l'enveloppe qui les entoure et concassés.
Mais attention, pas trop finement,
il ne s'agit pas d'en faire de la farine.
On doit sentir le grain, mais pas trop quand même.
Le tout est ensuite séché et tamisé.
Dans certains pays comme le Sénégal, la semoule de manioc
remplace celle de blé et on mange même du couscous de maïs au Brésil.
Aujourd'hui, on ajoute aussi
des raisins secs, alors ils ne figurent pas
dans la recette traditionnelle,
mais cette petite touche sucrée n'est pas désagréable au goût.
Vous avez toujours faim ?
Alors voici un couscous plus original.
Allez, on dégage la viande : l'agneau, le poulet, les merguez et le bœuf.
On garde les légumes et la semoule qui vont accompagner
du poisson.
En général, on y trouve de la dorade, du cabillaud, du mulet ou de la rascasse.
Ce couscous est excellent.
Il vient de Tunisie.
On le retrouve aussi très souvent dans la cuisine sicilienne.
Enfin, vous pouvez aussi vous passer de protéines animales
et vous contenter des légumes et de la semoule.
Des pois chiches, bien sûr, car ce sont les seuls qui vont vous apporter
les protéines nécessaires à notre organisme.
T'as encore oublié un ingrédient essentiel.
Mais bien sûr.
L'harissa
Cette petite sauce,
petite mais très forte, est obtenue à partir de piments.
L'harissa de l'arabe "harasa" signifie "écraser", "piler".
Au passage,
si vous voulez savoir pourquoi le piment
brule, pourquoi il arrache la gueule, comme on dit.
Reportez-vous à la vidéo que nous avons fait sur le sujet
et qui se trouve ici.
En général, il faut délayer l'harissa dans un petit peu de bouillon
avant d'en arroser la semoule.
Quoi qu'il en soit, tout ceci est excellent.
Celui qui a préparé tous ces ingrédients
aurait très bien eu sa place au Couscous Fest
c'est le championnat du monde de couscous qui a lieu chaque année
au mois de septembre à San Vito Lo Capo, en Sicile.
Le titre est actuellement détenu par des Italiens,
ils ont remporté la victoire
avec un couscous froid aux crevettes et au gaspacho.
L'année précédente, il appartenait à une chef roumaine
qui avait proposé un couscous à base
d'agneau, de rhubarbe et de jaunes d'œufs.
Elle avait elle même ravi
le titre à une Sénégalaise qui avait séduit le jury
avec un couscous à base de mangue et de poulpe.
Vous voyez, on est très loin de la recette traditionnelle,
mais c'est aussi ça le couscous, la rencontre de cultures différentes
qui se sont enrichies les unes les autres.
Et voilà,
chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux, j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
et que je vous ai donné envie de partager un bon couscous entre amis.
En attendant, n'hésitez pas à liker cette vidéo
et à nous suggérer d'autres idées de plats en commentaire.
Vous pouvez compter sur moi.
Je suis prêt à vous concocter d'autres vidéos.
Allez à très bientôt.